all right humans of the internet
this is the reuben report direct message
for thursday september 3rd
give me 24 minutes and i'll give you all
the news that i can fit into 24 minutes
pretty clever huh all right here we go
there's a lot happening in the world i
don't know if you know that uh it seems
like every story i think this is sort of
where we're at in the world at the
moment
is that it seems like every story is the
most important story everybody wakes up
you immediately go to your facebook feed
or your twitter feed or whatever feed
you're looking at
and it seems like everything is the
thing that's going to blow up the whole
system or
take it all down or whatever else is
happening but what i'm trying to do with
these direct messages as i
laid out yesterday is not bludging you
with
every detail of every little story every
little
political minutiae but sort of pick the
the big stories
uh and the big themes that are happening
uh each morning that's what i'm doing
with my producer michael we
talk about what's happening in the world
we pick a couple things to go through so
i'm really only doing three stories
today
and as i said we do this in 24 minutes
so uh
it's just a few minutes per story i'm
going to give you what you need to know
and hopefully you can take that and talk
about these stories with other people
and not get into fights and maybe
enlighten somebody or
learn something from from somebody else
okay so the so the big story i think
at the moment is that donald trump
the president do you know he's the
president uh donald trump
is considering withholding federal
funds from some of the progressive
cities that
seem to not be protecting their own
citizens from some of the cities
that we're seeing burning and looting
and the violent protesting and the rest
of it
trump is saying hey i am the president
of the united states that means i'm in
charge of the federal government
and if you guys at the local level so
first at the state level
and then at the city level won't protect
your citizens and your property then
we're going to withhold
funds from you uh so just to back up a
little bit and just give a little
sort of context to how the government's
supposed to work
is that most of the stuff that happens
in the city that you're in wherever
you're watching this from if you're an
american
the city that you live in the town that
you live in is supposed to handle most
of the stuff that goes on there meaning
the roads and the local laws and things
of that nature and then we build
up from there that's how our system
works so
most of the laws are related to your
town or city then within that you have
your state
and then of course you have the federal
government on top of that and
the founders set up the whole system so
that the federal government
meaning the government that's in charge
of the whole freaking thing
is actually not supposed to do a ton
because that gives more power to the
local governments to do things and
obviously if you live
in new york city what you need at a
local level in the laws
that you need or perhaps want at a local
level are very different than if you
live in an
in a suburban area of let's say
idaho right that's just obvious and
that's why you have local elected
representatives
and you decide where you want to live
these are ideas that i talk about on the
show often because i think our system
was set up quite brilliantly and yet
a lot of what we talk about especially
in the mainstream media
we've created such a cult of personality
around the president and this isn't
really about trump specifically but just
the idea that when you vote in a
president
you're voting in the guy who can do
everything
he's the guy that's going to save me
he's the guy that's going to make all
the things that i want to happen happen
and actually that's the reverse of how
the system is supposed to work he's
supposed to do
some things right the president is
supposed to be in charge
of protecting our borders for example he
is supposed to be in charge of foreign
policy for example
um but he's not supposed to do
everything at the local level so what
trump is saying in effect
is listen if you guys in new york in
seattle
in portland and washington dc those are
the four that he mentioned
if at the local level uh you mayors
will not allow your police departments
to defend
property to defend monuments to defend
people and we're going to talk about
defunding all of these things and the
rest of it
then what choice does the federal
government have other than to withhold
some funds that they give
to the states now there's there's a
couple philosophical issues here that i
think are
are really interesting so first off if
you if you believe everything that i
just laid
out there that the federal government's
not supposed to do that much then at
some level you're probably like all
right he's doing the right thing right
like
if that's the only lever he has right
like he could
send in federal troops he could send in
the national guard that sort of thing
and we can have a discussion about that
right because
if a mayor let's let's use portland
portland and seattle are really the best
two examples because i think we're
seeing the most violence on the streets
there
we're seeing mayors in portland and
seattle particularly
who are in my opinion in complete
dereliction of their duties i'm going to
do a separate story on ted wheeler who's
the mayor of portland
in just a couple minutes and if they're
not going to protect
their citizens and their property then
should the federal government send in
troops right should
they send in the national guard to
restore law and order now
you don't really want that if you if
you're for limited government you don't
really like the idea of the federal
government doing that but
on the other hand if you don't do
anything if the federal government
doesn't
do anything and then you have specific
places in the united states
where as misguided as the voters might
be they vote in
these lefty politicians who then allow
for
semi-autonomous zones as they had in
seattle and just basically anarchy on
the streets
as they have in portland if you allow
for that
within your country well then what is
the purpose of the federal government
what
what is sort of the national cohesion
that we have if some cities can burn and
some
can thrive now i think a pure federalist
would say well hey
uh that's tough right like if you live
in a city then and you're voting in
these morons then we're just going to
let it happen and it is what it is
on the other hand if we're to believe
that you as an american
that that me here in los angeles has any
connection to the person that
lives in dallas other than we live
in the same country but then the
question is well what is a country
and should we allow certain cities to
burn and all those things
and what levers can we push without
giving too much power to the federal
government so i think this is a really
interesting
play by trump i've said it a million
times you guys don't no i don't want the
feds
having to do too much but in effect he's
saying we're going to cut some funds to
these four cities
specifically his tweet was my
administration will do everything in its
power to prevent weak mayors
and lawless cities from taking federal
dollars while they let anarchists
harm people burn buildings and ruin
lives and businesses we're putting them
on notice today
so that's pretty clear and i personally
agree with the message there you know
there's a meme out there that somehow um
violence against
property isn't violence and this meme is
spread by the same people who will tell
you that words are violent so somehow if
you say a word that's violent
but if you actually burn down a building
or break a window that's not violent now
i suspect
if you're living in seattle or you're
living in portland
or you're living in new york city where
businesses are still shuttered
and the economy has crashed let's say
you're just really try to think about it
this way and maybe you are one of these
people
if you're a small business person
whatever whatever it is you own a
shoe repair shop or s or a coffee shop
or anything in between and you've put
your life's work into that
and then some thugs basically misguided
young people usually uh decide to break
your windows or just cause general chaos
in the streets so no one can get to your
store or you can't even open your store
this is all putting the the pandemic
issue aside it's like
if your mayor won't do anything to
protect your livelihood which you've put
your blood sweat and tears and life's
work into
it's like does the federal government
have to do anything and i think what
trump is trying to do trump is a
negotiator right so what he's trying to
do is he's trying to save these
progressive mayors hey i get it we have
a philosophic difference on
what's happening in the world right now
don't make me
send troops in don't make me send the
national guard and i'm going to withhold
money until you guys start taking care
of your own people
there were some other responses to this
uh new york mayor bill de blasio who is
uh possibly the worst mayor in all of
the country and that's tough when you've
got seattle and portland
and l.a in the same country he tweeted
while real donald trump
spent his year in hiding from covid19
new york city led the fight
back now we're trying to recover and
he's making unconstitutional
political threats against us mr
president we'll see you in court
we've beaten you there before and we'll
do it again i'm not sure what he's
saying is
unconstitutional but i suppose there
could be some
legal argument about what the president
can do
in terms of withholding funds if he's in
disagreement
with what a mayor is doing so there
might be some court fight there
the part that he said about uh new york
city has led the fight
back from kovid i've got a lot of
friends that are in new york city i've
also got a lot of friends that have
fled new york city and i don't think
anyone in their right mind thinks that
new york city is leading the fight back
against this thing i've mentioned this a
couple times but my own family's history
in new york city there have been times
since the early
1900s around 1908 that my family at
times has had about 70 people
uh living in new york city and the
boroughs brooklyn bronx queens etc
we are down to one i've got one cousin
remaining
in new york city my sister and her
husband and two kids just fled
about two months ago and now we're in
the suburbs
and that tells you a little bit about
what's going on in new york city
i've got a friend who's on the upper
west side right now and he said
everything is just
is just silent and quiet and shuttered i
used to live on the upper west i think
it's
one of the most spectacular places in
the world to live
but the idea that bill de blasio in new
york city is leading the fight against
kovid
is really quite bananas and then
portland
mayor ted wheeler had this to say and
this will lead us into
another story about portland's great
mayor who i'm pretty sure is just a
character
in the show portlandia at this point
wheeler tweeted trump threatens to
withdraw
funds possibly including health
education and safety net dollars
americans are relying on to get through
this pandemic and economic crisis
he continues to believe that
disenfranchising people living in this
country
to advance his petty grudges is an
effective political strategy
the rest of us know it is dangerous
destructive and divisive
uh well how about disingenuous ted
wheeler because
let's put it this way imagine if in
these cities in portland
and seattle washington new york city
imagine if the mayors were actually
backing up the police officers
not to make people not to have a violent
state rule of law and be hunting people
down
but just saying you know if you attack
property if you're attacking cars on the
streets if you're breaking windows
burning things down
we're not going to allow that rule of
law
if you don't have rule of law in in a
country in a city
in a state and you don't have a country
that is just true then then you have
just some sort of
uh rebel stronghold in effect
um so he's being very disingenuous here
because if
portland was just allowing the police to
do their job
seattle allowing the police to do their
job i have some friends in the nypd they
just want to do their job
they don't want to hurt anybody they
want to maintain law and order
and they do a pretty damn good job of it
i mean the new york police department is
under more pressure
than probably any police department in
the entire world and they do a pretty
spectacular job of it the idea that that
if trump would just go away
that that somehow these things would be
better is kind of crazy it's like
trump's not
saying i'm going to put the police in
dallas he's not saying i'm going to put
the police
in salt lake city et cetera et cetera so
this
this is a big mess and it's going to be
a big fight and i suspect one of the
things
that we're really going to see more and
more and more of
over the next five ten years and maybe
for the
real next couple decades in america
is sort of the battle between local and
state and i think generally that is a
good thing
but if big metropolitan cities are only
going to be run by progressives which by
the way this is then where
uh all the violence and gun violence and
all of the crime and everything else
takes place well then does the
uh does what is happening here
siri literally just started talking to
me she was under my leg and she started
talking to me did
stand by please did i say siri i didn't
say siri
that is disturbing as hell uh but in
effect i think that's what we're gonna
see over the next couple years that
if big progressive run cities are just
gonna crumble
what is the role of the federal
government and that's a great place for
us to have an honest real conversation
and i hopefully
hopefully we're able to do that we're
not particularly good at it
story number two which is sort of an
offshoot of story number one
is that portland mayor ted wheeler who i
was just talking about
uh he's moving and do you know why he's
moving
he's moving basically because of himself
his policies have led the people in his
city the the antifa
marxist blm activists to think that not
only can they burn down businesses and
set up autonomous zones
and do whatever else it is that they
want to do but they can actually also go
to people's homes so even though
this guy has been a total patsy for them
he's acquiesced
to virtually all of their demands he's a
lefty he
is a progressive right he's not a scary
trump conservative
he's a lefty he's supposed to be one of
them but even that
isn't good enough for them because the
thing is there is nothing good enough
for them it's an eight
what is happening with this blm marxist
progressive ideology is that
it's nothing other than for itself at
any given moment
so even though wheeler should be their
hero right these these lefty mayors
should be their hero but they actually
hate them so what happened
a bunch of activists showed up at ted
wheeler's apartment building his condo
building
and there was a violent clash there and
they were spraying graffiti on the door
and they were scaring people and setting
fires and breaking
windows and a whole bunch of other stuff
so
wheeler is now moving because of wheeler
wheeler is wheeling out okay
he said i want to express my sincere
apologies for the damage to our home
and the fear that you were experiencing
due to my position that was part of a
letter
that he sent to the other people who
live at the condo and basically he's
gonna get
out and like you really gotta think
about how bananas this is his solution
is not
to stop it right it's not to think oh
maybe some of my policies
have led to the ever-encroaching
violence that is now
literally at my doorstep
but instead of doing that i'm just gonna
leave
i'm just gonna leave does he think he
can live somewhere else safely in
portland
or is is the mayor not allowed to live
in a condo right like i guess he can't
live in a condo because if he goes to
another condo well they'll just take it
to the other kind of so does the mayor
have to live
on a mountain side somewhere you know
does he have to live in a some sort of
suspended
uh giant tower somewhere in portland
do they have one of those i'm not sure
uh anyway
it's just such a perfect example
of what is wrong with progressive
policies
they think that not only if you just
strip the law
back that you'll be okay but that
eventually
it won't come to you and the thing is it
will come to you every time
all right enough about uh portland
let's move on to the nfl it's it's a
wonderful story actually the nfl
has decided to end racism they're gonna
do it that's right
everyone else is just talking about it
but the national football league is
gonna
end freaking racism you know how they're
gonna do it they are going to put
a call to end racism in the uh
in the end zone that should do it i mean
we were just
waiting for some kind of message you
know what i mean i guess the nba tried
it they put black lives matter on the
court
and now ratings are tanking uh and
people are just
sick of the endless politicization
of sports i have trouble with that word
for some reason
uh but people are just sort of sick of
it but the annabelles decide if we put
some anti-racist messages
in the end zone we're gonna solve this
whole thing uh
they will also be adding social justice
phrases
to the end zones in the 2020 season
which of course mirrors activism that's
engaged
by the nba and some of the other sports
leagues so the reason i thought this was
an important story
even though you know it sort of sounds
like oh you're just talking about a
sports story
but you know as as we've been talking
about for a while now
we're running out of spaces in the
public sphere
that are not political and that isn't to
say that
a athlete or even or a team owner
or an organization can't talk about
politics or express their views or any
of those things
but my personal belief is that once
you're on that
court once you're on that field it has
to be
about the sport you're playing and
that's it that's why we
love sports like whatever sport you're
into i'm a big basketball guy but
whatever sport you're into if you're a
baseball guy
or a hockey guy or a football guy or a
soccer guy or whatever it is
why do you love sports why do you watch
sports why do you play sports
you do it because you love competition
you love the athleticism you love the
engagement and the rivalry and all of
those things
and when you sit on a on a sunday
afternoon whether it's to watch an nfl
game or a basketball game or whatever it
might be
you're you're having a human experience
of someone else at
hopefully the peak and apex of their
athletic life doing things that you
could never do in it like it helps make
makes you dream and it can bring out
real emotions in you
and for anyone that's a real sports fan
you've most likely cried
when when your team lost in the finals
you know uh
my my favorite player i've got a
basketball signed by him right behind me
was a huge star in the nba in the late
80s and early 90s clyde drexler who
played on the portland trail blazers in
the houston rockets
and the famous moment unfortunately for
clyde is game one of the 1992 finals
everyone remembers this even if you're
not a sports fan
when michael jordan hit six threes and i
think scored 35 points in the first half
and there's that moment after he hits i
think the fifth or sixth three in the
first half
and he just shrugs because he can't even
believe it
can't even believe it and you can see
cliff robinson who actually just passed
away a few days ago i found out about
that
while i was off the grid only 53 years
old
passed away another player who i loved
you can see him just crumble to the
floor behind
clyde ended up winning a championship a
couple years later so it all worked out
for him
um but like i remember watching that
moment and like
dying inside and then when clyde won a
ring a couple years later it was like i
won a ring that's what sports is all
about
and the more that we make sports about
politics about
all of the stuff that none of us can
escape from we're actually destroying it
i mean you really have to think about it
this way i really believe this
the athletes that are injecting
politics and race into everything
are actually destroying the sports that
they love
so when when lebron makes it all about
race or whatever it might be
or any of these guys do this colin
kaepernick it's like do more people like
football now because of colin kaepernick
or do more people not like football i i
definitely think it's the latter
people are just like oh well why would i
want to give these guys my money or when
you boycott
when nba players boycott playoff games
in
in the name of protesting racism uh
did you did you expand the fan base of
basketball that pays your
you know multi multi-million dollar
salaries that any of us would kill for
i assure you people as much as i love
doing this doing what i'm doing and i'm
certainly doing okay by it i would quit
this in a freaking
second to be an nba player but if the
nba players keep
destroying their own league maybe the
future of sports will be washed up 44
year old guys with no acls on their
knees and a bum shoulder
playing basketball because it'll be more
fun so actually keep at it guys
um but but this general idea uh
that they are going to paint i mean i
kid you not they're gonna they're gonna
paint phrases
like end racism in the in the end zone
uh and it takes all of us and racism
we're all for ending racism there's
virtually nobody that doesn't
want to end racism
that doesn't mean there aren't racists
there are pocket racists who will always
exist
racism and fear of the other and
xenophobia is is part of the human
condition and the best thing you can do
is
show people why it's a bad set of ideas
but the idea that every single
one of our things you know it's not just
that you open up ubereats there's a
message about racism
you turn on apple tv there's a message
about racism
this is actually making the system more
racist it's making us all focus on
something that we in america
have gotten past in a way that almost no
society has ever gotten past
in in a in a speed and a fashion which
is incredible for such a young nation
a young a nation that fought a civil war
over slavery to end it and we did who's
already had a black president
there are there are nations in europe
that have existed way longer than the
united states that haven't had black
prime ministers or leaders that in and
of itself doesn't mean we're
racist or not racist but it shows you
that something really good has happened
here
uh and the uh the quote from richard
goodell
who is the commissioner of the nfl he
said the nfl stands with the black
community the players clubs and fans
confronting systemic racism
we will not relent in our work now he's
a white guy and of course he will be
destroyed by this
right the next commissioner obviously
will be a black man and no matter how
much
penance he pays to the to the cause here
he will be destroyed
of course he also doesn't describe what
systemic racism is
they just say it as if it is true and if
you're a little confused as to whether
systemic racism exists or not
i would highly recommend you watch my
original interview with larry elder
where he beat me senseless and woke me
up to the myth
of systemic racism and there's many
other videos that you can watch on that
on that note that was 24 minutes i gave
you everything i got i hope you feel a
little more enlightened and a little
less of a political headache at the
moment and i hope you can take some of
this info
and get out there and fight for what you
believe in and we'll be back at it soon
enough